in this video I want to talk a little
bit about glycogen its structure and its
function why we care about it what's
important about it things to know
so glycogen as we mentioned before when
we talked about carbohydrates is a
polysaccharide of many alpha D glucoses
specifically alpha polysaccharide of
alpha D glucose is linked by alpha 1-4
glycosidic linkages
what is glycogen suction glycogen is
basically a storage form of glucose it's
a way to store glucose we're in in our
bodies is it stored where as the
glycogen located it's located primarily
in the liver and muscle so basically it
stores muscle or stores glucose and a
chain like this that I'll get to in just
a second for for energy that we can use
so if there's too little blood or too
little glucose in our cell there's not
enough and we need to free up some
glucose then our bodies can take start
breaking down glycogen free up glucose
is that our cell can use or if there's
too much glucose around then our body
can store that glucose in the form of
glycogen now is it a form of long term
or short term storage depending on who
you ask you might get different answers
but the way I like to look at it is that
it's a short term form of storage and
the reason why is typically your body
will tap on three things for energy
glucose in the blood or that can just be
taken up by your cell or glycogen or fat
and glucose is the first thing that that
is used because it can be readily tapped
on and go straight into glycolysis the
next thing that can you know almost as
quickly be metabolized is the glycogen
you just free up glucose is and then you
use those in glycolysis but fat takes a
little bit more time a few more steps to
actually get get going so I would I
would consider fat the more of the
long-term storage form of energy whereas
glycogen is a short term but it's not
the shortest term form of energy storage
anyway what's the structure like we
already said it as connected in a chain
by alpha 1-4 glycosidic linkages and
that's actually what I've drawn here so
if you already recall these are alpha
1-4
Oh civic linkages right where the one
carbon is connected to the fourth carbon
um an interest in a chain by alpha
linkages right here's the one for
linkage here's one for linkage but now
it's not just one long-chain glycogen
has branches and specifically these
branches are via alpha one six like
pacifica linkages that's what I actually
what I've drawn here the one carbon the
anomeric carbon is connected to the
ch2oh on an another glucose that's part
of another glycogen chain so this tan
alpha 1-6 glycosidic linkage mm-hmm
excuse me and so so these these linkages
allow a glycogen to be branched now
before I go on I want to talk about the
ends of a glycogen chain so if we
imagine this just this like kitchen
chain as opposed to this this branch
being included there are two ends there
is this end with the free Oh H at the at
this particular carbon which we if you
recall is called the anomeric carbon so
if the end that has the free anomeric
carbon is considered the the reducing
end so a sugar basically we talked about
it earlier about how a sugar with a free
Oh H group but it's an America Arbonne
is considered a producing sugar and that
basically means that it can exist in
equilibrium with the open chain aldehyde
or ketone form whereas the non-reducing
end this end here the non-reducing ends
cannot cannot exist in the open chain
form because because of the Vyasa tell
that that is formed this alpha 1-4
glycosidic linkage so these ends here
are considered the non-reducing ends
okay
and oops non-reducing and now why is
this branching important for glycogen
it's highly branched I only drew one
branch here but you can imagine that
this change is much much longer there
are tons of these branch points
so why is this important the reason why
is because if we want to take off if we
want to break down glycogen and you know
free up glucose is we're going to take
them off of the non-reducing ends so if
it was only one long chain then we could
only take off one glucose at a time we
would only have one glucose at the
non-reducing end but if we branch it if
we have these branch points here then
you can imagine that we have tons and
tons of not non-reducing answer as many
of them and what that allows for those
many non-reducing ends that allows for
quick breakdown allows for a quick
breakdown of glycogen for for glucose
right to free up glucose that can go
through glycolysis so instead of just
taking off one glucose at a time I could
take off this one this one and this one
at the same time because I have two
non-reducing ends but in reality
glycogen is highly branched there's many
many many not reducing and as opposed to
just one long chain so that's it for the
glycogen structure and function I hope
that was a good introduction thank you
for watching